now overseas Turkish Turkish officials
reportedly obtained recordings proving
how Washington Post writer Jamal
khashoggi was killed The Post reports
American officials are aware of the
audio and the video footage it
purportedly shows a Saudi security team
killing khashoggi inside the Saudi
consulate in Istanbul now some senators
want to block the sale of US weapons to
Saudi Arabia
president Trump rejected that idea
yesterday as to whether or not we should
stop a hundred and ten billion dollars
from being spent in this country knowing
they have four or five alternatives two
very good alternatives that would not be
acceptable to me Ouiser Jang is at the
White House we do good morning good
morning John president Trump says the
u.s. is working with Turkey and Saudi
Arabia to find out what happened to
Jamal khashoggi he says he wants to wait
for more details from an investigation
before deciding how to proceed but he is
facing growing pressure from lawmakers
who are calling for immediate action
Khashoggi who is a critic of the Saudi
regime was last seen 10 days ago
entering the Saudi consulate in Istanbul
Turkish media aired images of what it
described as a Saudi hit squad allegedly
flown in to kill khashoggi CBS has not
independently verified that information
a US intelligence source tells CBS News
there are signs that Saudis may have
planned to take a show V into custody
and then back to Saudi Arabia now media
companies executives and journalists are
pulling out of a Saudi investment
conference scheduled for later this
month that usually draws some of the
world's business elite on Capitol Hill
lawmakers from both parties say the
Trump administration must hold the
Saudis accountable and that the u.s.
must stop doing business with them if
there is evidence implicating the regime
but president Trump says there are other
ways to handle the situation and he's
arguing to preserve that 110 billion
dollar arms deal to keep money flowing
in to the u.s. biana story becomes more
and more disturbing we show thank you
thank you